raymond devos qui publie aux éditions
stock alors un recueil de 75 sketch
intitulé sens dessus dessous alors tout
de suite avant de parler de son
entourage espère répondre au cld est
sensible au fait que êtes assis ce soir
dans un fauteuil se sont assis avant
vous
des écrivains aussi prestigieux que jean
d'ormesson bertrand par audel flèche
françois mitterrand quesnel c'est là je
suis très sensible
merci de votre présence ici vous paraît
quand même plus logique absurde je suis
très flatté je me sens pas tout à fait à
ma place pour dire bon pourquoi mais
parce que parce que je suis un homme de
scène puisqu'il faut parler sérieusement
je suis un homme de scène et alors ce
n'est pas parce que mes textes sont
édités que je vais me prendre pour un
homme de lettres
je lis moi pas non bon alors vous êtes
l'auteur de ces soixante quinze sketches
ces points qu'ils symbolisent les crises
il n'est pas utile je veux d'abord
savoir quel est le sens du titre sens
dessus dessous
oui parce que je c'est difficile à dire
en huile ou demain sans sud souvent ces
sangsues dessous c'est le titre d'un
sketch voulait même bien alors ça vous à
l'ensemble un bon titre pour le livre
mais moi vous savez le monde sont déjà
je l'emploie très souvent mon escaich le
premier livre qui est senti ça peut ça
n'a pas de sens parce que finalement
peut-être que le sens du comique est un
sens très particulier c'est tout de même
devenu un sens mais l'emporté le
chercher chez l'homme il homme a le sens
du comique ou quand il dessine la base
c'est parce qu'elle est malade
voilà tout laisse penser que tous les
spectateurs lausanne
mais j'en suis persuadé j'ai persuadé
que le sens du comique c'est un sens
indispensable celui qui en est privée je
le répète encore c'est un type qui ne se
porte pas bien parce que c'est sept
jours m c'est comme l'homme qui s'est
fait qu'il s'est forgée la possibilité
de riz
c'est donc que c'est indispensable à sa
survie bridge en plaques désigne pas
appeler des grandes stars mais attention
oui donnez à la pole a maintenant il n'a
pas le sens de l'humour
pourquoi audi ne s'appelle pas me sens
dessous dessus mais parce que b non
parce que déjà j'ai pas ce que j'ai fait
c'est quoi c'est ce qui s'appelle pas
sens dessous dessus
il aurait pu s'adapter aussi se dit ça
aurait été encore plus absurde que vous
chercher des noises
oui à chercher des poux dans la tête
oui oui mais vous savez alors j'ai vous
dire j'ai hésité très longtemps
c'est pour ça que sa maman lui de parler
de ça parce que je me suis dit est-ce
que sans dessus dessous sans dessus
dessous
au sens dessous dessus je me suis dit
qu'est ce qui est mieux ben alors qu'il
a mangé patron des arbitres je me
préserve y promet une pleine de bon sens
je vous dis recomposer un grave problème
à davos et kloten rage c'est que demain
évidemment je les rangées de ma
bibliothèque puisque j'ai déjà lu
l'émission sera fini je ne sais pas le
classer alors voilà est ce que je puis
le classer parmi les romances on se
prépare il ya beaucoup de personnages y
allemand alors les romances vous pensez
qu'on peut le classer dans les remarques
n'ont pas bon alors alors je vous pose
une autre question je posais à tous les
auteurs tous les grands auteurs c'est
l'impression votre livre finalement
s'est déguisée une autobiographie
alors est-ce que non mais enfin vous
avez raison vous avez raison parce que
c'est ma façon de voir donc absolument
absolument
j'ai pensé aussi le ranger au rayon la
philosophie et je vous signale
d'ailleurs convention la philosophie
mais seriez entre des cartes et du
recueil n'est quand même pas mal pour un
bien
est ce que est ce qu'on a fait
oui par ordre alphabétique évidemment
est logique
vous avez quand même pas faire d'humour
ce sens un peu de philosophie
j'allais dire malheureusement parce
qu'on marque branchée un jour de faire
de la philosophie
pourquoi ici c'était un péché les limbes
et si tout en mouvement je vous dirai
pas le nom réputé très connu alors oui
alors quand j'ai vu ça alors que je
pense qu'on ne peut pas faire de comics
en tout cas le mourre assure mais du
comics en faire un peu de philosophie
forcément alors celui qui a dit ça
c'était non vous faites la morale sans
le vouloir
j'admire obligatoirement parce que une
histoire comporte toujours une moralité
surtout quand elle est absurde c'est
fantastique de prouver moralité à jour à
mesure
c'est ça qui troublent un bon bain ac
non normal c'est le gigal bête parce que
ça amène forcément quelque chose
voilà donc c'est normal raymond devos
c'est parce que c'est normal que ces
troubles
raymond devos page 63 à la partie
j'écris des choses absolument on est
arrivé on est bien par ouï oui mais plus
les choses absurdes plus j'ai
l'impression de lire des vanités
si c'est une espèce de dons mais non
mais c'est assez fantastique a constaté
rené donc je pars sur l'histoire que je
sais pas ce que j'allais dire qu'il n'a
ni queue ni tête
c'est fantastique tout d'un coup ça vous
retombe pas